. In the immediate, there is no better time
than now to talk a little bit about the plans
for people who are voting in very blue states
and in very red states who maybe are planning
to vote third party.
Maybe you're planning not to vote at all because
the outcome in your state is essentially determined.
Now, as most of you probably know, in the
United States, we don't have a national popular
vote.
We have an electoral college.
So if you win a state as a presidential candidate
by just one vote, you get all of that state's
electoral votes and it has no impact on what
happens in other states.
It's really 50 individual elections because
of that system that we have really.
The election is determined by a dozen or so
battleground states or swing states, as they're
sometimes called.
So these include places like Wisconsin, North
Carolina, Ohio, Florida, etc.
And it's very common that people in very blue
are very red.
States who are on the left will say to me,
I get these phone calls.
I hear from people in person, et cetera.
They'll say, you know, I live in Utah.
Biden's not going to win.
I might vote third party or I might not vote
or whatever.
And then I'll hear from people in states like
my state of Massachusetts who say Biden is
winning by what is it at this point, 34.
It's crazy what Biden is winning by.
In Massachusetts, it doesn't really require
my vote to make sure Biden gets Massachusetts
electoral votes.
So I might vote.
Maybe I'll vote Green Party to give them some
support or whatever.
If there was ever an election where that is
not the approach that we should have, it is
this one.
If there was ever an election where every
blue state and red state voter needs to make
sure that you are voting for Joe Biden, it
is this one.
And you probably can guess why I'm going to
make this point.
There is a very real possibility that Donald
Trump will claim that the election wasn't
fair, that it was rigged, that the results
are wrong.
And in particular, if it's very close nationally
or within the key states that end up being
the determining factors.
We may have a situation where not only do
we not know the results on November 3rd, I
mean, with the number of mail in ballots we're
going to have, it's certainly reasonable and
not a problem for me that maybe we don't know
the results until November 6th or 7th, 7th.
I want the right results rather than the fast
results.
But put that aside for a second.
We could again end up with a situation where
the Supreme Court gets involved here.
And some people sent me a clip of Sam Ceder
recently talking about this, saying we might
not know who won on Tuesday.
And Trump will in all likelihood claim that
he won.
Lawsuits may start in a variety of different
states and it could be a never ending battle.
So we need a large margin in every single
state.
And also we want the largest possible popular
vote margin.
Why?
Well, because if it does get to either secretaries
of state or Supreme Court justices, the more
overwhelming the defeat is of Donald Trump.
If we are going to get one, the more difficult
that's going to be for Supreme Court justices
to justify funny business.
We'll leave it at that which could end up
handing the election to Donald Trump.
There's no guarantee.
As we know, the Supreme Court is liable to
do anything at any time.
But the point is winning the popular vote
by three million votes, which is roughly what
Hillary Clinton did in 2016 while still seeing
Donald Trump become president with an Electoral
College victory.
That's just going to be too close.
And if this extends a few days into weeks
because of lawsuits and on and on into the
Supreme Court, particularly while Donald Trump
is trying to kneecap the Postal Service to
try to prevent a vote by mail, absentee ballots
from being delivered, we need to do everything
we can to avoid small margins anywhere.
We want to avoid small margins in the states
that will be close.
We want to avoid small margins or smaller
margins than we could have in California and
Massachusetts.
We need to run the score up.
And if the election comes down to a couple
of states and the popular vote is closer rather
than less close, it just better enables Donald
Trump to claim whatever the hell he plans
to claim.
If we overwhelm the vote so much that Trump
is crushed in the popular vote, the claims
are just slightly harder to make seriously.
California has millions and millions of Democrats,
and Joe Biden's clearly going to win.
Who cares?
Go out and vote and run up the score in California.
Massachusetts will.
Easily go to Joe Biden.
You'd better believe I'm going to be voting
and encouraging everybody I know who votes
in Massachusetts to be voting.
Everybody has to vote because we have to.
I don't know of a better term than to run
up the score.
And then and only then, if we succeed in removing
Donald Trump, then we go back to what I discussed
earlier, which is we will have to deal with
Trump ism and the 60, 62, 64, 66 million people
who will have seen the last three and a half
years and will say, yeah, give me another
four years of that following.
Sam Cedar's logic on this, which I think is
sound.
It's possible that overwhelming margins could
sway one Supreme Court justice.
You don't have to if it's going to be five,
four in some decision over some lawsuit that
Trump files, if it's going to be five for
an overwhelming popular vote.
Big victory swinging.
One of those nine votes could make all the
difference in who ends up being president
as of January 20th, 2021.
And voting is something we can all do.
It's our right.
Let's exercise it.
August twenty third is the 15 year anniversary
of The David Pakman Show.
We will have a huge membership special.
I can't say any more about it because it's
borderline illegal, certainly immoral, but
maybe even illegal in some states.
Be notified of this great membership special
by grabbing a membership.
I'm sorry.
By getting on our newsletter at David Pakman
dot com, you will then on August twenty third
be notified of how to take advantage of this
great membership discount.